hello there reject nation we're gonna
watch today
from a channel joeboar1777
the batman teaser trailer like you know
the one robert pattinson but in lego
format
um how i discovered this video was i
followed co-screenwriter of the batman
matson tomlin online and he replied to a
tweet
from jeremy borchers saying may i
present the batman teacher trailer in
lego and this is actual like
motion animated kind of dealio he
replied to it saying
strong so i was like this must be cool
this must be good i see on twitter it's
been blowing up 759 retweets
so that's pretty damn good for uh like a
twitter
account that only has 779 followers it's
really good so guys if you end up liking
this video i
encourage you to go check out the actual
video itself in full screen on his
channel
subscribe to joeborst1777
let's see what's in store
[Music]
it's like the version of the lego batman
we will never get yeah that's awesome
[Music]
from your secret friend
[Music]
[Music]
wow
dude this is
this great really well done great use of
lenses too
is it a penguin outfit
why
damn straight you are oh i want this
i want this lego batman
[Applause]
[Music]
wow bravo bravo
yeah dude that's brilliantly done
yesterday
perfect eye shadow lego format too
hell yeah hell yeah
oh so cool
wow it's a collaboration
well this is a lot of work you got to
put in for this man
oh man
oh wow how many people worked on this
they're saying that tweet looking back
on that tweet
oh this deserves more views on youtube
this deserves so much more views
absolutely wow that's a lot of people
well yeah it looks like literally every
different major scene or shot had its
own
studio working on it or something my
goodness or its own yeah just team of
lego animators i mean i thought it might
have just been one guy but
to see that it is like a whole team of
people that came together who've been
like probably chipping away at this
since the day of its release like how
how did they form this what was the
inception of this what was the nebulous
of how this all started
they must all watch it be like we gotta
work together on something they just got
in this like giant conference call
we gotta put this together all right
we're gonna delegate yeah you take this
sequence and you take that sequence we
all need to pull our legos together or
take apart anything that could be useful
that's in black
because this is in stop-motion format at
least that's the language i
know so that must be it right um so it's
in that kind of format and i've seen
people who have done like the batman
trailer and lego format but not to the
degree of like
hyper stylized animation and the way
they've brought that to life the way
they've realized it is great it feels
like you're watching a dark version of
like one of those lego movies you know
yeah yeah well it had like a lot of
really tangible elements too that
in contrast with the lego movies it's
like the water that's moving
around in the rain sequences like it's
the benefit in a way of having to do a
singular frame each second because the
water drops are inevitably going to
change but it also looks like a very
convincing rain effect yeah like little
things like that or
one thing i noticed heavily was the
lenses they would choose would create
the very cinematic
you know depth of field so that you
would have like yeah the very soft
background and then batman and hyper
focus in the front
and so yeah those things help to immerse
you even further and i think not to
slight anybody else's lego films online
this looked like they probably at least
had a few extra camera resources on hand
and a lot of legos to work with yeah
so you know it seemed like they were
able to get as much as they needed to
realize this to a certain extent so it
is like a little more
i guess professional looking to me but i
would love to see
more stuff like this or more films
reinterpreted trailers this way
i mean yeah it's hyper detailed hyper
painted yeah
it's gorgeous to look at and i love like
with the certain emotions of times where
it just looked really badass but
especially with the i'm vengeance moment
i think that's what we're all
waiting to see now maybe in an actual
lego movie
they would have like the actual fist
punching but you know having the
self-awareness of the actual
legos and then using it makes it feel
like they really use real legos here
which they did
yeah and so to use real legos and honor
the movement of legos i think is
actually a really cool touch as opposed
to trying to
make it look hyper cgi or something like
that you know
i feel like if it was the real lego
movie they would just undercut that
entirely and cut out to real legos and
just throw
each other something but i even love
like the littlest things like the
newspaper clipping moments uh early on
when gordon's looking at it and the
freaking duct tape man with that
long lego piece extending just like
those little clever things that are that
are knowing of legos yeah
also knowing of this trailer inside and
you're right about those rain shots they
do look
gorgeous they do make it feel a lot more
cinematic um
yeah this was great this is this is
really awesome i would love to see an
actual behind the scenes on what they
did to compose this particular one oh
yeah how everybody approached it
because i'm sure nobody did it exactly
the same thing
you know they must have built the dodge
charger right
yeah and they do have lines of like in
fact i just built a lego mustang the
other day that is a little bit more
along these lines of like it's an
actual kind of car not just like a
little teeny thing yeah
yeah and so like the cars all across
this video i thought were great but to
have
like the flame on it too yeah and then
to have like the penguin outfit because
i was wondering how they could bring
like colin farrell's playing one of life
so they couldn't
warp the face yeah but he had like the
penguin outfit on
um i loved like the batarang looking
i'm just so impressed with it and i was
wondering before going into this with
actually batman himself if you would see
his eyes but i liked how for the
animation here they decided to go with
the white eyes batman
like fully you know yeah it's gonna have
like a blend of like of course
mainly looking to honor and operate on
the terms of
this is the batman trailer brought in
lego format but also there are times
where you're like ah it looks like it's
out of the comics that's even cooler
right yeah
and kind of combined like each element
this was like my favorite thing about
just the lego movie concept in general
but also a diy lego video but also yeah
a comic book but also the movies yeah
like
it kind of suspends it in this weird
middle area where it gets to occupy all
of the layers of both whimsy but
tangibility
yeah you know because this was again
like i'm a fan of the lego batman movie
i don't
love it but like this i did kind of get
endeared by it in a wholly different way
because i feel like there's a certain
idea that these need to ride on comedy
if they're in a stop-motion lego form
and while i think there needs to be some
level of whimsy there
like this took itself seriously enough
that i was like i feel like you could
probably do a lot with
those you know and do a lot that's very
distinct and creative because yeah you
do have the choices between what gets to
be a lego and what gets to be a physical
element
and this too was just again also the
lighting like
was very impressive to me because the
lighting's impressive the movement is
really impressive
too i felt like they had a variety of
different kinds of movement throughout
this feels like okay this is the last
step before like someone swoops in is
like you guys need a proper studio now
because you could be doing this on a
big level this one pops a lot man this
is great this was it's made my day a
little bit
guys subscribe to this channel if you
haven't done so already we gotta
go through everyone who's listed in this
description
all their channels what'd you think
about it leave your thoughts down below
hit that like button subscribe to us if
you haven't done so already
last but not least
i think it's appropriate that for an
animated video the one person we should
shout out today
is erica tuesday i haven't heard from
you in a little bit erica i hope you had
a really great halloween
in knowing you you probably did
something that was reasonably creative
yeah i don't know what to do it's like
some kind of hospitable gathering yeah
of a small variety givens
you like horror do you like style guys
follow erica's fan page her facebook
page where's that page john
that's at erica tuesday art on the
facebooks
she does a lot of different kinds of
stuff i mean she works for dreamworks
currently so if you're into that kind of
animation she does that but she's also
got a
wide range of beautiful and also darker
suited to like a batman style thing
darker art as well she's got a great
breadth of expression
and erica you're just a great human
being and so uh it's it's a new month
and uh in a way to avoid the november
blues i'm thinking of you
so hell yeah thank you erica hope you're
doing well dear much love